welcome back everybody so X Twitter
employees are coming after new eat CEO
Elon Musk after they claim his
widespread layoffs targeted women a
lawsuit filed Wednesday notes that 57
percent of last month's layoffs were
women the complaint also mentions that
musk has been quote widely criticized
for sexist demeaning and hostile
comments he's made against women showing
discriminatory animus the plaintiffs are
seeking several outcomes including a
declaratory judgment that Twitter
violated federal anti-discrimination
laws they also want quitter to quote to
quote reinstate female employees who
wish to return to their jobs and see
seeks compensatory punitive and
emotional distress damages an amended
complaint in a separate lawsuit was
filed the same day and it claims the
company's layoffs targeted workers
either on or about to be on medical or
family leave
Terry Twitter has been in some hot water
since Elon Musk has taken over what do
you think the future of the social media
giant looks like you know what the
future does not look bright for Twitter
bought more freedom on the platform but
then he immediately blocked certain high
profile users like comedian Kathy
Griffin and Kanye West known as Yi other
high profile users they subsequently
decided to voluntarily stop using the
platform then musk proceeded to lay off
half of the 7500 Twitter employees and
those layoffs definitely affected the
morale of the company and to make
matters worse musk demanded that the
remaining employees sign a document
pledging quote extremely hardcore work
whatever that means so this lawsuit is
definitely going to have a negative
impact as far as Twitter's concerned
yeah I think that's definitely
definitely true Brian the lawsuit makes
a number of arguments gender
discrimination termination of employees
and they go on and on about you know
parental leave and failing to provide
notice of termination are these winning
claims I think they may be uh I I look
at this as kind of like what my law
professor said in school is the it's a
bundle of sticks argument that one stick
may be pretty weak but you put them all
together it makes for a stronger
argument uh I'm looking at the numbers
when they talk about discrimination 57
of women were uh were were fired while
only 40 for seven percent of men I don't
think that Elon Musk had any concept of
who he was firing I think he was just
coming in and just chopping heads left
right and center and so I think that
might make a strong argument for him but
the question becomes is his
um termination of people indirectly
discriminating against people and having
the outcome that he maybe did not
perceive that may be an argument
especially when you talk about the
procedural effect of not giving people
due process it's an interesting legal
argument to say the least we're gonna go
over now to Wisconsin where a Christmas
concert with Patti LaBelle came to a
very sudden end because of a bomb threat
okay
[Applause]
the singer was rushed off the stage by
security and officials evacuated the
pack theater someone reportedly called
The Venue saying there were explosives
inside Milwaukee Police did a search
with K-9 units but thankfully no
explosives were found a woman at the
show told media Outlets that LaBelle had
only sung two songs when the rest of the
concert was canceled a celebrity trial
is underway in Los Angeles as two
rappers one male and one female face off
in a high profile assault case Tory
Lanez whose real name is Daystar
Peterson is accused of shooting Megan
the stallion whose real name is Megan
Pete in 2020 the two were attending a
party at the Hollywood Hills at the home
of Kylie Jenner police were called after
reports of gunfire and Megan and lanes
were in a car with Megan's now former
best friend Kelsey Harris and when
police got there Megan told them that
she had stepped on glass when in reality
she claims Lanes shot at her feet in an
interview with cbs's Gail King Megan
said she was afraid of the police and
how the situation could escalate so she
died but when she got to the hospital
the doctors found bullet fragments in
her feet Lanes has maintained his
innocence and the judge is not allowing
any Electronics in the courtroom but law
and crime senior reporter Megan cuniff
is inside and we caught up with her over
the phone on Monday
he has denied being the shooter I talked
to his lawyer over the weekend and he
said he didn't want to you know give
away his case too much but he said they
will be arguing that Tori was not the
one who shot Megan here and the only the
the person who's in the car who it all
seems to be pointing to through Tori's
comments is Megan's former best friend
Kelsey Harris and it sounds like Tori is
saying that there was some romantic
interest between him and the two women
that caused a conflict between the two
women so it sounds like that's really
going to be Center to Tori's defense
here
all right I'm joined right now by my
host and public defender Brian buckmeyer
Brian we're also hearing some of the
defendant's side of the story but
through his music what can you tell us
about that yeah Jesse for over two years
now this trial has been argued through
albums social media interviews and even
SNL performances but with opening
statements beginning on Monday the hope
is we'll finally learn what happened
Megan is expected to testify on Tuesdays
but what happened that night well she'll
likely say that a drunk Tory Lanez shot
at her feet shouting dance than a word
My mama taught me not to call a woman
her story is that she was shot and had a
surgery on her feet now Tory Lanez
defense argues of the case is about
jealousy and by listening to his albums
he released months later album Sorry
after the incident Day star supposedly
Megan's assistant Kelsey Harris who was
in the car during the shooting had
gunshot residue on her hands and that
she was the shooter some of his albums
saying how did you get shot in the feet
foot without the tendons being hit
opening statements are going to be
revealing a lot we'll see how this case
continues oh I think they will but
moving over now the Civil side I want to
bring in former trial Attorney Terry
Austin so making the stallions performer
she claims that she received these
injuries to her feet I think she could
bring a civil lawsuit for damages you
know
you know shocked that she hasn't brought
a suit already because
for him she uses her feet she dances she
sings and if in fact she has injuries
and she can prove those injuries he was
negligent and there's a difference
between negligence on the Civil side and
criminal negligence obviously the burden
of proof is different it's lower it's a
preponderance versus Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt so she could recover but here's
the thing the statute of limitations may
have expired already it's two years in
these types of cases so unless she filed
a claim and we just don't know about it
she may be time barred at this point to
bring a civil action against him but if
she did she could recover a lot of money
yeah well a lot of moving Parts in that
case I think we should continue to
follow it's very high profile indeed
well Tuesday marks one month since for
University of Idaho students were
stabbed death in a brutal attack that is
haunting that Community the students
were sleeping on the second and third
floors of a home when they were killed
now so far while police have said that
the attack was likely targeted they
haven't identified a suspect or they
found or nor found the murder weapon but
last week police did ask the public to
call in any tips about a white Hyundai
Elantra seen near the crime scene police
released body cam video showing an
unrelated call about an alcohol events
and in that body cam footage you can see
a white car which is a lot of people
talking but the chief offered
clarification
so the body cam managed that is out
there from an officer who was on a call
with alcohol offense does have a white
vehicle in it this is not the vehicle
that we are looking for so we want to
clear that up with all news media the
tip line now will go to an FBI call
center we've done that because we
started receiving many many tips and
that call center can categorize those
and they can send those tips back to
investigators so we can follow up and
make sure that we continue with our
investigation
now it should be noted that some of the
chief's attention has been taken away
from the actual investigation to focus
on rumors surrounding the case so we
want to take a moment to highlight some
of the biggest inaccuracies inaccuracy
so far so the department says that
online reports that the victims were
tied up and gagged are not accurate
there have also been reports that a red
red Mustang just blocks away from the
crime scene was being processed as part
of the murder investigation but the
Moscow Police Department says that that
too is false and a red Mustang is not
connected and also despite claims
otherwise the identity of the person who
called 9-1-1 about the deaths has not
been released